British Prime Minister Theresa May is
still battling to get Parliament to
approve her brexit plan as she tries to
renegotiate her deal with the EU on
Thursday May suffered another
humiliating defeat in the House of
Commons lawmakers voted against a motion
supporting her approach to brexit probe
regs at MPs and the Prime Minister's own
party abstained from the vote saying she
is moving in the wrong direction the
vote is non-binding but it is likely to
undermine EU leaders confidence that May
can win Parliament support for any type
of agreement
let's bring in DWS Birgit mouth she's
covering this for us from London hi
Berger so Theresa May is really getting
nowhere with Parliament she's also up
against a brick wall in Brussels what
can she possibly do to save her deal
well one way out would be to somehow
soften her red lines around the customs
union possibly the single market that
would mean she could get some support
from the Labour Party but she makes no
sign of willing being willing to do that
and as such we really are in a situation
where everybody is at loggerheads with
each other to resume with her Parliament
but also with the European Union so
there is no obvious way out the
accusation is that Teresa may is just
playing for time and she's running down
the talk towards the end of March
because that's really just a few weeks
left until the UK would crash out the
European Union if there was no
compromise found we have heard that
accusation Birgit there in London also
in the u that Theresa May is indeed
running down the clock is there anything
to that yes there really seems to be no
other strategy at the moment at least
there's nothing that's visible from the
outside that ariza Mae has any vision of
how she could move the process forward
and where she actually wants to lead the
country there are lots of MPs here in
the UK were deeply worried that by
accident the UK could crash out without
a deal that would have serious
implications security implications
implications for business
huge uncertainty and there have been
calls also on ministers to prevent that
to possibly resign so that that reason
may could be prevented from doing that
nobody once said the EU doesn't want no
deal Theresa May doesn't want a no deal
the British Parliament doesn't want it
and yet it could happen if no solution
is found the truth is we don't know
there's going to be another crucial rate
in two weeks time here in the UK in the
meantime syriza may wants to negotiate
with Brussels but what's going to come
out of it we simply don't know at this
stage Berger a lot of unknown still as
you're saying but with six weeks to go
until March 29th until the UK supposed
to leave the European Union what
scenario looks most likely at this point
in time this is really the
million-dollar question I think a lot of
people here in the UK me included would
still hope that there is some sort of
deal because it would be terrible for
the UK to crash out and parliamentarians
all experts know about how serious that
would be also for the European Union not
being able to to somehow find it find a
compromise and and and keep a friendly
contact with their with the UK so a lot
of people are hoping but it looks as
they as if this could be really a very
very last-minute scenario alright Berkut
Maas for us in London thank you very
much so the UK is scheduled to leave the
European Union at the end of next month
as we said people in Germany have never
liked the idea and the latest polls
confirmed that in its latest ad or
content opinion survey for the German
public broadcaster ard via poster infra
test de map found that only 16 percent
of Germans welcomed the idea of brexit
an overwhelming 79 percent of Germans
surveyed say they regret that Britain
intends to exit the EU well let's bring
in Ryan Hache linkit he is the managing
director of in for test
D map Institute so a big majority of
Germans as we said there would still
like to see the UK stay in the EU does
that surprise you after all of the
yes and also bad will we've seen from
both sides here no not at all it doesn't
surprise me because when he when you
look at the image of the EU in Germany
it's absolutely positive there's only a
minority of 14% of as the EU has its
disadvantages a disadvantage to Germany
and when it comes to the questions do
you do you and have more national
possibilities for the nations themselves
it's only a quarter of Germans say that
what won't and for Germans the EU stands
for free circulation of people and goods
it stands for peace in Europe so it
doesn't surprise me at all looking ahead
to a very big election here in the EU
between the 23rd and the 26th of May
voters in the European Union will decide
who they will send to the EU Parliament
now the greens and the far-right
populist AFD are both on the rise
conservatives and Social Democrats so
the centrist parties are declining is
that in line with the overall trend in
Europe well we're a little bit later we
will see their voting the so-called
Sunday question we will see them in our
broadcast right now but of course the
discussion about the climate threatened
throughout the world the discussion
about social inequality helps the Green
Party halves the Left Party and you know
the question of immigration has been
helping the right-wing parties but
nevertheless you will see that the
right-wing party in Germany is not as
strong in the European election
predicted as it is in the national
elections for the next bonus that you
mentioned that just there a mr. slinko
at national elections so let's take a
look at that question if elections were
held this weekend let's take a look at
how things would stand here in Germany
Chancellor Merkel's conservative bloc
the cdu/csu would win 33% of the vote of
the Greens would be at 19 percent of the
Social Democrats would come in third at
18 percent of the far-right AFD who
we've just been talking about would get
about 10% the business-friendly FDP we
get 7% and the far left left party would
get around 6% so mr. Jaffe you were
talking about this that the European and
German political landscapes looking very
similar right now why is that how do you
explain that
yeah not extremely similar because the
CDU has four percent more in the
European election nationwide it's at 29
the SPD has the same one and the
right-wing party the AFD has three
percent less in the projection for the
European election so it's not exactly
the same people see that the governing
makkal party has a strong European back
hold and they see that the right-wing
party which is mostly protest party in
Germany doesn't play the role in the
European election it would play the
national election here in Germany
alright I not Schlenker
managing director of the info trust Dima
Polling Institute thank you so much
pleasure